you hear the voice of the original Mario
speak in one brief Cameo from the movie
and did you realize that wasn't the
first time we've seen Mario and Luigi do
that rap together these are the things
you missed in Super Mario Bros so like
did you catch the reference in the
movie's opening scene if you're paying
attention to Bowser's moving Lair it
looks a lot like Bowser's lavalaire from
Super Mario Galaxy 2. on team Bowser
you'll see blue shell Koopas kamik an
antagonist from the franchise ever since
his introduction in Yoshi's Island
behold the king of the Coopers and
bullet bills Bowser takes on an army of
penguins who you may recognize if you've
ever played cool cool mountain in Mario
64. but in the end Bowser opens a
question mark block something that's
been part of the series since the first
Super Mario Bros game and he earns
himself a superstar which for those of
you who need a reminder is a power up
that grants the player's invincibility
now who's gonna stop me and all of this
is back by a pretty incredible score the
Easter eggs in Super Mario Bros aren't
only on screen you have to listen for
them too composer Brian Taylor teases
that you can find hundreds of references
to the game in his music like when Mario
Peach and Toad pick out their rides for
Rainbow Road at this moment you can hear
the selection music from Mario Kart 8 in
the background
[Applause]
[Music]
a remix of the invincibility theme plays
when Mario and Luigi hit the Superstar
and you can hear the underground theme
when they go into the New York sewers
but it isn't only the games getting
referenced you know that cheesy rap
Mario and Luigi do or the Mario brothers
and plummets again well that was a
direct reference to the Super Mario Bros
Super Show from 1989.
and that isn't even to mention the
Easter eggs hidden in the musical
moments what did you think about the
character's songs
[Music]
especially Bowser belting out his
feelings for peach while playing the
piano Jack Black actually wrote peaches
himself and as much as it makes sense
for them to play into Jack Black's
skills as a musician that isn't the only
thing you should be paying attention to
here look closely at the piano Bowser's
playing you can see it has Ludwig von
Koopa inscribed on the side of it and
Ludwig von Koopa is the eldest and
possible leader of the Koopalings who
have served as minor antagonists in the
video games ever since they were
introduced in Super Mario Bros 3. Ludwig
von koopa's name and design have always
been a callback to Ludwig van Beethoven
so it sort of makes sense to reference
his character in such a musical way just
like it sort of makes sense for you to
subscribe to our Channel if you're
enjoying our video but for now let's
move on to another classic reference so
that Mario and Luigi cheesy rap scene
actually led to a pretty iconic Cameo
later on in the movie when Mario asks
about the Italian accent he put on for
the commercial the man who answers him
sounds exactly like Mario does in the
games he's even sort of dressed like him
so what's the deal well as it turns out
that character was voiced by Charles
martinet who's been providing us with
the voice of Mario since 1991. hello
Mario and not only that but the
characters he's playing can also be seen
using a Jumpman arcade cabinet and
Jumpman was the original name for Mario
in his first
1981 appearance Charles also takes on
the role of Mario's dad for the couple
of scenes where he appears as a cute
sort of Nod to the way he handed on the
role to Chris Pratt to become the newest
hero for the Mushroom Kingdom the Easter
eggs seem endless when Mario arrives in
the Mushroom Kingdom right away he
encounters the bug-like bitty buds of
Super Mario 3D Land but it's once they
get to town that things get really
interesting you can see the coins from
the games being deposited out of blocks
by toads like some sort of ATM we see
that toads Get Around by using clear
warp pipes like the ones in Super Mario
3D World oh wow
and what else okay so these bricks are
just floating here yeah those have been
around ever since the first Super Mario
Bros game Princess Peach's castle looks
exactly as it did in Super Mario 64.
right down to the paintings of different
Landscapes along the walls like the ones
that the players use to access new
levels in the game the Super Mario Bros
movie definitely went out of its way to
include some obscure details did you
recognize form and Spike he's introduced
into the movie as Mario and Luigi's boss
but long-term fans of the game May
notice that he looks a bit familiar well
that's because he served as an
antagonist for the brothers in the 1985
game Wrecking Crew where he was the
foreman of a construction site where our
heroes worked at he just generally serve
as an annoyance by removing platforms
taking things and doing other things
that would slow down the player's
progress but otherwise he was just doing
his job despite this we wouldn't see the
likes of him again for several years
that is until the Super Mario Bros movie
brought him back and reinforced that he
was still still the boss of our iconic
duo in one way or another and Foreman's
bike isn't even the only old school
character from the games who was brought
back for the movie
Pauline is she was introduced at the
very same time as Mario as the lady he
needed to rescue in the original Donkey
Kong arcade game which we'll be talking
about more later as you can probably
tell her history with the Mario universe
is Rich but she was sort of brought back
for a more modern audience in Super
Mario Odyssey where we got to see her as
the mayor of New donk city which is sort
of like the Mario verse equivalent to
New York City now unfortunately we don't
get to see new donk City at any point in
the movie but we do start out in its
real world counterpart and apparently
Pauline is still in command if you look
closely at the news broadcast that
announces rampant flooding in Brooklyn
you can also see that mayor Pauline is
there trying to soothe the public and
talk to reporters she's even wearing the
exact same red pantsuit that she was
seen wearing in Odyssey Donkey Kong is
even introduced with a reference when we
first see him he's brought out to the
tune of the DK rap which was actually
the song that opened up the game Donkey
Kong 64.
here we go so when Donkey Kong squares
off against Mario in the movie he pulls
out some pretty memorable moves throwing
barrels like he does in the Donkey Kong
game and rolling just like he does in
the Donkey Kong Country game Mario is
even almost beaten in this battle
becoming winded and dropping his famous
it's a me line but he's got to get to
Bowser's wedding Mario is able to turn
the tides by donning the Cat Mario suit
that was first introduced in Super Mario
3D World you got the cat box this moment
also gives us a brief Glimpse at the
character of Diddy Kong who was Donkey
Kong's partner in Donkey Kong Country
were you at all surprised when you found
out that Bowser's plan involved marrying
Princess Peach it's a plot we've heard
before but it's a classic so we'll let
it slide and besides we can't deny that
he's looking pretty stylish wearing the
exact same wedding outfit that he wore
in Super Mario Odyssey and that guest
list was super impressive we have King
Boo of Luigi's Mansion King babam who
serves as the first boss in Super Mario
64 4 and Petey piranha from Super Mario
Sunshine a few special power-ups from
the games help our heroes to turn the
tides and save the day before the
credits roll too like the Ice Flower
Peach uses at the altar to rescue the
prisoners and Mario's Tanooki suit from
Super Mario Bros 3 which helps him to
fly did you stick around until the final
moment the Super Mario Bros movie went
full on MCU and gave us two post-credit
scenes the first one gives us Bowser
crooning another version of peaches but
it's the second one that's really worth
hanging around for this one shows us a
strange egg that then shakes crakes and
gives out the familiar Cry of the Yoshi
Chris Pratt has already teased that this
moment gives us our first glimpse into
what we can expect to see in a Super
Mario Bros Sequel and says that he's
very very excited about the possibility
that we'll get to see our favorite green
dinosaur in the next one with so many
Easter eggs and references to the games
like it's no wonder why some are saying
this movie feels like Love Letter are
there any other references you noticed
that we maybe didn't include we're all
huge Mario fans here so make sure to let
your thoughts be heard in the comment
section down below